you
first of all professor David my warmest
congratulations thank you so much Rick
topeka when I made postdocs of yours
they have many good things to tell me
about you you're an extremely creative
man and you even welcome bad ideas how
can bad idea to be good I think their
ideas that I think about I've come to
realize that although I tell people
they're bad ideas often their ideas are
much better than my ideas and then they
say to me what if you think they're bad
why don't you wonder you even talk about
it but I say you know just so you'll
know how I'm wrong and then you stick
with your own idea and you'd be right ah
I think your creativity is well known
now you get a prize for it what gets you
going the only science is really excited
actually 19 seats people but up till now
I thought it was numbers in science but
actually like people as well this is a
big surprise to 40 why I'm enjoying this
week so much do you think science in
general it means more playfulness yeah I
think every passionate witty media
presence
then alter their super that works to be
into it in many ways but I do think that
you have to work very hard to care what
you're doing to contact yourself
seriously I have that this man never
grows up what not I'm happy not to
prolong I don't see any advantage of him
growing up I mean I get older it's how
to walk up stairs somehow I think that
one can continue learn to be any
generation right now my guru is my
tenure grants teaching about music and
everything I want to know xboxes and
video games he says I'll never learn I'm
not sure no you know um you work became
a huge success did you see the potential
in you work during the 70's yes we
certainly saw the potential very early
on but of course you never know how have
things are going to play out in some
sense of leasing potentially is not the
same as the communities Invitational I
think that in many ways a decision of
the chemistry committee was a surprise I
don't think any more would have
predicted particular papers of a
selected
is it a very very tender courageous
thing
so if we just play with assault with it
press the fast forward button and I ever
heard that you mentioned that simulating
life could be possible in the future I
think I feeling a living cell life is a
very broad concept and but I do think
that there was a born of life to pay
because understand the basic machinery
of life you should we should be able to
simulate more and more complicated think
obviously there's a certain amount of
randomness and uncertainty but I don't
see any fundamental reason why we
couldn't submit a wholesale I'm going to
all human being may take another million
years I don't know please get better
over time I mean one cell could easily
be too free but the trouble is that
complexity I think that and in substance
is your right to this when we started
out with assimilating few hundred atoms
for a very short time and I was reading
even millions of atoms what's surprising
is nothing has gone wrong and that's
actually quite surprising she could have
thought suddenly things which just
stopped working so it does seem that as
computers become all-powerful we can
actually do bigger and more copy of
things which is not necessary expected
a little bird told me that you report a
guy and the last name will you live up
to that tonight I hope so I think that
my color is kind of tight my shoes are
not the most comfortable shoes I
happening Bahamas carbonated vodka
sparkling vodka so I think it's gonna be
a fun party I'm definitely even my
guests who are leaving at 6am are coming
to the nightcap after parties SE e on
the dance floor a very happy evening to
congratulate me so much pleasure p